the ideas instead of a programmer
specifying or writing a program step by
step with every statement instead of
specifying the complete logic what if we
can allow programmers to specify their
intent for they want the program to do
at a high level you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen Hughes
inga everyday computers take on more and
more of our daily tasks fill in a few
cells on your spreadsheet
it'll fill in the rest ask your car for
directions it'll get you there any more
we can program computers to do almost
anything but what about programming
computers to program computers that's
the task that dr. bishops Singh and the
team in the cognition group at Microsoft
Research are tackling with neural
program synthesis also known as
artificial programming today dr. Singh
explains how deep neural networks are
already training computers to do things
like take classes and great assignments
shares how programmers can perform
complicated high-level debugging through
the delightfully named process of neural
fuzzing and lays out his vision to
democratize computer programming in the
brave new world of software 2.0 that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
rishabh singh welcome to the podcast
thanks a lot Chris yeah great to have
you here
great to be here yeah sir research
resides under research in software
engineering or the Rhys group and MSR
but your specific area is the relatively
new group just called cognition tell us
what goes on brief you talk about that
so about couple of years back we formed
this group called cognition where the
idea was how do we build the next
generation of AI systems that go to its
general intelligence and the idea was to
bring together people from deep learning
reinforcement learning and programming
languages such that we can build systems
that can learn complex algorithmic tasks
so for example actually we have seen lot
of recent breakthroughs in deep learning
where systems have achieved even
superhuman performances on recognising
images understanding text speech but one
thing that has been there amongst all
these successes is that these net faults
were their learning are still relatively
simpler models tasked with these
networks learned patterns but to get
towards more general intelligence we
need systems that can learn to perform a
complex sequence of tasks and that was
something when we started this group we
wanted to build these next generation of
Mitford architectures that can learn to
generate programs and and more broadly
we call this area neural program
synthesis basically training much in
these networks to generate programs ok
so let's do a little bit of a level set
because our audience is fairly
sophisticated as you know yeah but I
always like to do a layman's version of
what we're gonna spend a half hour
talking about and you've sort of alluded
to it already but give us a kind of
definition of program synthesis because
that's sort of the Nugget of what you're
working on and why we need it yeah
that's that's a great point actually so
the idea is instead of a programmer
specifying or writing a program step by
step with every statement instead of
specifying the complete logic what if we
can allow programmers to specify their
intent what they want the program to do
at a high level so some examples might
be maybe we can specify the intent by
either using a few number of
input-output examples
or test cases or maybe natural language
and the goal of program synthesis is to
take those under specified
specifications and in generate program
that are consistent with it now the
reason we need program synthesis is
first not everybody who's using these
sophisticated software systems might be
professional programmers so for them to
be able to get maximum leverage out of
these systems we can enable them to also
perform complicated tasks by having
simpler mechanisms for them to specify
the intent one example is let's say
Microsoft Excel where millions and
millions of users use this system but
not all of them are programmers they
come from various backgrounds if we can
allow them to specify the indents using
examples or natural language then we can
really democratize the notion of
programming so that's one reason I am
quite excited about that but even for
more sophisticated users let's say
professional programmers there are many
tasks that are quite tricky and complex
instead of them having to reason about
it all manually we now have efficient
search algorithms that we can leverage
to remove some of that burden out of
these programming tasks and let the
Machine perform that kind of tricky
reasoning and have programmers perform
more high-level reasoning you gave a
talk and that people can find on the MSR
website called programming synthesis for
the masses right and you talk about
democratizing computer programming which
sounds like what you've just explained
right there yes yes is taking a very
complex activity programming a computer
to do something you want it to do but
allowing it to be accessible to you
mentioned students and users and
programmers right is there more to the
masses I mean would it be useful for
someone like me who is I think they're
new and new applications people are
using program synthesis for for example
there are no speech systems where
somebody can specify their high-level
intent using speech for these voice
assistants and then in the backend the
idea is to take that high-level
specification and break it down into
smaller sub tasks and then compose them
to perform the
tasks that the user intended to do
sweating some flavor of these techniques
are now being used in almost everyday
use cases now in there are many classes
of users and I believe your programs in
these techniques can help pretty much
any scenario so are you aiming for a
time when I could just articulate what
I'd like to do and then the computer's
resources that it could draw on could
actually take cues from me and execute
exactly that's so the vision that we
want to get towards I think certain
domains we can first target to do such
things for example in Excel let's say a
user can specify what they want to do
I didn't natural language of speech and
then we can have the machine in the
background search over the space of
programs and then find one that fits the
ending and then B can be many other
domains very ways something like that
could be possible for my benefit can you
explain when it says search over the
range of programs what kind of programs
would it be looking for yeah value goes
back to the definition of program
synthesis the VV frame this problem is
it's essentially a search problem where
the goal is we have some programming
language it could either be Turing
complete specifying all possible
programs or it could be domain-specific
as I was saying maybe for programs
inside Excel or programs for web
extraction but the search problem
essentially says that a programming
language defines a space of programs
that could be written in that language
and given a specification the goal is to
search over this large space of programs
to find one program that satisfies the
specification users provided so it's
this giant search problem and that's why
actually it's one of the hardest
problems as well because the search
space is coming is actually in some
cases even infinite because if the
language allows for recursion and
arbitrary expansions yeah there's a
giant space and a lot of research that
happens is how to make this search more
tractable or how to actually make this
search process more efficient in
different domains that sounds like
you've got your work cut out for you and
a lot of research opportunities over
there next I don't know years this
exciting part yeah I think we've already
had
quite a few recent breakthroughs and and
certainly recently with more advances in
hardware in CPU speed and then also
newest search methods like deep learning
techniques and in constraint solving
people are not trying to combine these
newer techniques to make the search
process even more efficient
[Music]
you know I read a lot of your papers
before this podcast and one of them was
called artificial programming that one
resonates to me because that makes sense
I get what you're saying it's like
artificial intelligence artificial
programming but it is programmed
synthesis yes right exactly we were
trying to think of a better way to
describe this whole system but actually
one more motivation of defining in that
way was there's been a lot of work
previously in program synthesis which
has mostly been based on rule-based or
more algorithmic way to perform search
which has required lots and lots of
human insights to make the search
tractable and in this case actually what
we were trying to do was can we frame
the learning problem in terms of
learning abstractions using neural
networks and that which was related to
artificial intelligence so that's one
thing but on top of that there are
several other benefits we get if we can
learn programs first that we can learn
interpretable models
so whatever the network is learning
since it's producing a program one can
look at what the network has produced
they can debug the learnt programs they
can modify it if it doesn't work the
right way but at least it's more
interpretable than the current networks
that are basically learning a set of
low-level
weight matrices and also one more
benefit we get from learning programs is
that these models tend to be more
generalizable so these programs tend to
also work well on newer inputs or newer
data sets that we have not seen in
training that was actually a question I
had in trying to wrap my brain around
this because having talked to a couple
of other researchers out here on
programming languages specifically
there's so many of them yeah and we fall
into different categories and they're
each useful for a particular kind of
task and within program synthesis how
does it sort through the kinds of
languages that might be useful for that
particular program I mean is that part
of the search yeah that's the session
excellent know some point yes a lot of
research actually also goes on into
designing these languages the task is
actually we want to design for any given
domain we want to come up with languages
that are expressive because we want it
to be able to express many
many tasks in that domain but at the
same time we want to constrain it such
that it is easier to learn or perform
search in some sense so so there's this
always this trade-off between
expressivity and conciseness of the
language and a lot of work actually goes
into designing languages specifically
for program synthesis and actual similar
things have happened in our work as well
we have been looking at various domains
designing various domain-specific
languages for different program
synthesis applications and since we
wanted to get towards a system that can
learn programs in a very general purpose
language we have been taking steps
towards adding newer features one at a
time to start from maybe a very small
language then adding few features and
then getting towards a complete language
let's say like Python or
[Music]
the work you've done in neural program
synthesis for learning string
transformations in a functional language
like autofill and flash fill for Excel
but you've got this recent work using a
more challenging imperative language
Carol in which you if you built this
program that took an introductory
computer science class and passed I
don't think it was a grade you might
have been happy with but for a machine
was pretty good yeah tell us that story
so flash field was the system we
developed view is back for Excel users
to enable them to program using few in
purple examples for string
transformation but this was mostly an
algorithmic system where we came up with
new efficient ways to search over the
space of programs in the domain-specific
language we designed for flash fill and
we were actually quite happy that that
we can build these systems that can
learn programs in in a language like
flash field which is mostly a functional
language it's learning composition of
functional abstractions then we wanted
to see a few what happens if we make the
language a little bit more complex so
what if we can add a bit of control flow
over these functions like loops and
conditionals and interestingly enough we
found this language called Carol which
is taught in Stanford's
introductory programming class students
they're basically given a set of
input/output voice where robots are in
certain position and they're markers and
in blocks and so as I've write these
programs in the Carol language to
basically move robot starting from the
input well such that it ends up in the
output world and that was one of the
reasons we chose Carol because it had
control flow and it added one level more
complexity over the flash field language
secondly as you mentioned region we also
wanted to see actually how well it would
do and not just learning programs that
we generate in the language
synthetically but also can it solve
problems in a class test sitting that
students typically go through and it was
interesting that when we trained the
system to perform program synthesis in
this language for the class test right
now it was able to solve seven out of
sixteen problems which was yeah which is
still a
I think better than what we expected but
we're now improving the system to get
even better yeah so it needs to get
better grades in order to you know give
the parade yeah so the hope is actually
keep improving the system and then we
can see how well it performs compared to
yachts human programmers that are also
learning the program from scratch which
is interesting because you're like
working side by side with beginning
programmers and this program that's the
beginning programmer exactly right right
so the hope is actually these systems
also starting from somewhat scratch and
then maybe in the beginning they're not
so good at learning program but over
time over experience they are getting
better and better and that's also one of
the things we want to look at in future
where right now we're training these
systems individually for every domain
full flash field we were training a
separate system for Carroll we are
training a separate system is there a
way we can leverage knowledge across
domains can we build a system that
actually learns from experience is not
just in one domain but be able to
transfer the knowledge to other domains
as well so doesn't that kind of lead
into the work you're doing an inductive
programming basically this leads towards
the notion of general intelligence that
humans we are able to learn something in
one context and then use it later on we
don't have to learn everything from
scratch in the same way right if we can
build a system that can evolve over time
and continuously keeps adapting itself
and improving itself from experiences
that will lead to its more general
intelligence yeah so I guess where I was
heading with the question is like you
talk about these very specific tasks
with the specific languages within Excel
or within Carroll or so on and the goal
eventually would be that these systems
could work among the different kinds of
things and make the same kinds of gains
that humans do with their general
intelligence yeah absolutely right and
also similar to humans right we are able
to write really complex and large
programs in general-purpose languages so
if we're able to learn across domains
hopefully we can also increase the
complexity of the domain-specific
language in which we are learning and
hopefully at some point it becomes
almost a general-purpose language so I
used to teach English and I know it's
like to stare at a stack of essays
overwhelmed
by the task of having to grade them and
make meaningful contributions and I I
often remember thinking I'm only ever
going to be asymptotically approaching
zero I'm never gonna get this stack done
tell me the story about Auto grader and
our shared experience our shared pain
and what you did about it actually this
was this was something that started when
I was a teaching assistant for the
internet reprogramming class at MIT and
I should be used to go through the same
process we had few hundred students in
the class and they would submit their
programming assignments and quite often
actually this would happen they would
make small mistakes in their programs
and if we just give them traditional
feedback that says either your program
works or it doesn't work first of all
there might be just some small mistakes
and we are penalizing students for that
and secondly there's no meaningful
feedback to students as well about how
they can improve if we just say pass or
fail so that's why actually when we will
T is actually uses go through each
program manually try to understand what
the problem might be and gives a more
detailed feedback on what might be going
wrong and and how they can think about
improving their solutions and then
actually around similar time EDX was
also starting out and we decided to also
offer this introductory programming
class on EDX and the scale there was
completely different from the classroom
setting we had maybe 200 students in the
class whereas on EDX I think the very
first offering had more than hundred
thousand students sign up and there was
no way actually we can manually go
through all the submissions and give
meaningful feedback and then actually
that's when the notion of this notion of
auto-graded or giving automated feedback
to students came up the idea was
actually since specifically in programs
in programming courses will be thought
actually program synthesis might help in
this setting so let's say a student
submits a solution for any given problem
now there are many many different ways
to solve the same problem there many
different algorithms and even for a
given algorithm there are many different
programmatic choices one can make
because the languages are very
expressive so we cannot just come up
with a solution that can do any kind of
syntactic reasoning because that would
be too much work and
it's not even possible to come up with
all possible ways students are going to
solve the problem but that's where we
can leverage program synthesis the wave
frame this problem was given an
incorrect submission can we find minimum
number of changes to the original
student submission that is incorrect
such that it becomes functionally
equivalent to teacher submission and one
thing that this spinning system needed
was basically a teacher had to come in
and define a set of common mistake
students are making so there was a
little bit of teacher effort but that
wasn't too much and in the hope was once
that is there then it could be reused
across multiple years and more similar
assignments so that was something we
were doing when I was at MIT during my
PhD but afterwards when I came to
Microsoft research we have the learning
experiences team here that also offers
many many interesting courses on EDX
platform which is quite interesting and
this is lovely to talk to them and we've
been collaborating with them now to also
build these systems to help students
taking those courses but one interesting
thing we have recently done is to also
reduce the amount of effort teachers now
need to do so instead of teachers having
to specify space of edits or changes we
leverage all these previous students
emissions since the scale is quite big
we can actually automatically try to
learn the space of changes from the data
itself so our current Issa's order
grading system basically just speaks a
set of previous submissions a few
thousands and then automatically learns
the space of changes and then uses
programs these techniques to find
changes to new student submissions so is
this actually in use in a lot of venues
yeah so educational venues we just
deployed it one version of it I think
few months back to the c-sharp
programming course here at Microsoft so
currently we are still doing some
studies about what level of feedbacks
are actually more helpful to students
because we can either give a bit of hint
about saying this there's something
wrong about your program at this place
or we can go all the way and say here's
the mistake and this is how you want to
change it so we've been right now just
taking initial feedback and trying to
see what different kinds of
feedbacks what can you affect it hasn't
students and what is the right time to
provide what kinds of hints let's talk a
little bit about neural networks and how
kind of this neural deep learning is
representing what some people are
calling a fundamental shift in how we
write software some of effort to it is
software 2.0 right tell me about that
yeah so actually this is quite
fascinating I think we are changing at a
rapid pace now and as AI is becoming
more and more prevalent and then we are
using newer and newer machine learning
systems as cool part of our software as
a result of that I should not all
software is written by humans or
programmers specifically so there are
all these components that are typically
learned from different data sets so so
it changes the way we think about how
software is going to be developed in
future since many part of it is are
going to come from these learnt systems
we need ways to effectively manage how
to compose piece of code that is written
by programmers piece of code that is
coming as a black box from outside a
learnt model and at the same time it
also introduces many challenges your
first is interpretability that if we are
just using black box model it's hard to
really give guarantees about what
exactly is happening these are going to
be stochastic models so we we will have
to write code that somehow understands
that variability and tries to ensure
that even if it is off by some amount
the software will still be making
reasonable decisions this is hard task
in itself yeah that's a great challenge
the way I think about software 2.0 going
forward is we are going to have a shift
in how programmers think about
programming in the sense that they don't
have to specify each and every step of
the computation imperative ly they can
actually provide the intent and at more
high level concepts like test cases or
maybe partial programs they can write
piece of code but keep
some parts of the code empty or maybe
natural language they can specify what
they want this particular function to do
and then we're going to have these
synthesizers or smart compilers that
rotate these ambiguous under specified
intent and convert that into code for us
or something that we can execute it's
still unclear what exactly that future
is going to be sure and hopefully at
some point will converge to one common
framework where we can have this notion
of multimodal specification where we
allow all different ways to specify the
intent and have these smart compilers or
synthesis systems that can understand
them and generate code that satisfies
the intent so the sensational way of
describing software 2.0 is that at some
point humans will stop writing code and
the machines will take over but what I'm
hearing is that this complementarity of
humans and machines is going to remain
and that it's never going to be you know
this is gonna replace software 1.0 yeah
that's actually a great way to put it
yeah basically it's not the case that
the goal is to replace programmers the
goal is actually to empower programmers
to achieve even more and even here
actually programmers still need to
provide the specification or intent or
what the sensor system needs to perform
the way we have evolved over time we
used to have these low-level assembly
languages in the beginning where
somebody would go in and write all these
low-level assembly instructions move
data from one register to another then
we evolved into high-level languages
where the idea was instead of writing
assembly code will have compilers which
will go from high-level languages to
assembly and programmers can actually
specify
write their programs in a high level of
abstraction and then we'll have these
more even smarter compilers that can
take those kinds of ambiguous or under
specified intent and still be able to
generate code that is consistent yeah
we're not going to replace programmers
but just make them even more or
obviously make everybody a super
programmer right so along the spectrum
of ability you're going to make
professional programmers be able to do
better at what they do
and programmers that aren't even
programmers be able to program within
specific parameters right yeah exactly
this is whole spectrum in the sense yeah
we can make developers even more
predictive but yeah there's this large
class of audience who are not
necessarily developers or programmers
but we can also enable them to perform
tasks like programmatic tasks in various
domains without having to know how to
program things yeah to be able to afford
them to specify what they want the
system to do it a high-level abstraction
and let the Machine generate the code
for them it's really exciting I mean
that's enabling access to what's usually
been reserved for a very small subset of
the population on the planet yeah and
that's something I'm actually most
excited about where we can build systems
which can enable people from all
different professions to use computing
and achieve these tasks that require
programming yeah of some sort yeah so
let's talk about fuzzing for a minute
regular fuzzing versus neural fuzzing
will you unpack that for us sure yeah
let me let me start by Fitz buzzing so
fuzzing is this process which is that
quite remarkable success in almost every
software company the idea is actually a
we want to write code that is secure
that doesn't have any bugs and the idea
of fuzzing is actually to automate some
of that testing process so instead of a
human or a tester writing these programs
to test the idea is we'll have a process
that can generate random inputs it can
either take an input put it randomly
again and again and check if any one of
those inputs crashes the system then we
know there's something wrong with the
code and we also have an input that
triggered the bug it has been actually
quite successful in in various companies
and it has found many many safety
critical bugs or security bugs so this
works quite well for binary formats
where the inputs are let's say an image
and I can put up pixels and check if any
one of them crashes the system or leads
to some vulnerability but when we have
more structured input formats let's say
a PDF file or a word file or a docx
format
problem is if we make random changes to
those files very quickly they would
become invalid files and the parser
would just say oh this is an invalid PDF
file so one of the challenges is how do
we do fuzzing for these more structured
formats such that we can still generate
new random inputs but that still adheres
to the grammar of the format and that's
where we were using some of these noodle
synthesis techniques to be able to learn
grammars and over time it turns out
actually it's able to automatically
learn some notion of grammar of these
formats that makes the fuzzing process
much more efficient it only generates
good-looking inputs and it also reflects
then and when we were trying out these
new systems that are augmented with
these neural grammar learning techniques
they are able to generate inputs that
cover more parts of the code and they
also find many more crashes than the
current state of the art system so that
was also a really nice application of
learning high-level representations of
different formats it's actually
interesting now with recent advances in
these learning techniques the systems
are becoming more efficient so now we
are seeing more and more usage of these
learning techniques for fuzzing
[Music]
talk a little bit about your path to
Microsoft research from your beginnings
in India what got you into this and how
did you end up here of all places
oh that's that's quite deep yes so
actually I'm growing up I was in India
and then I did my undergraduate at Ida
Couric in computer science so I really
like mathematics but at the same time
this notion of being able to automate
things by writing programs that was
quite fascinating and I joined MIT after
finishing up my undergraduate degree to
do research in software verification
that was my starting point but then
slowly I got more interested in program
synthesis where instead of writing code
and then doing verification what if
actually we write code that was correct
by construction so then after graduating
I was considering academic positions and
micro research and I really liked the
atmosphere here we had great sets of
researchers but also I think MSL it has
some unique advantages compared to
academic places which I really liked and
then I decided to be here and it's been
almost three in our four years now and
I've seen quite a lot of fun yeah so as
we think of your future what excites you
right now what are you working on I know
you're you're sort of nugget is program
synthesis but is there any new thread
coming off of that this guy you really
actually that's something at microphone
which was quite unique compared to other
places when we formed this group
cognition group we were able to bring in
researchers from many different
backgrounds come together and work on on
this larger vision of doing noodle
program synthesis and for a long time we
were using more algorithmic and more
rule-based systems to perform search
whereas I think the fascinating thing
has been in last few years we've been
building these architectures and
learning such algorithms from data
itself and that's something I'm actually
quite excited about and also this notion
of actually combining these more neural
a proof
with more symbolic approaches and this
combination of symbolic AI and neroli is
something also quite exciting and that's
what something in the group also we are
hoping to explore it even more going
forward yeah if you had to say at the
end of your career this is what I would
define success as in my field what would
be the definition of success so I think
one of my dreams I don't know when we
will ever get there or if we will ever
get there but so so right now we are
able to synthesize small snippets few
lines but if we can build a system that
can actually be able to assist
developers write sizable amounts of code
from high level specifications or high
level intent that would be quite magical
if we can do that
and that's one of my dreams that may be
end of the career if I can see that
happening that would be super fantastic
yeah Rashad Singh it's been great having
you thanks a lot Gretchen for having me
yeah escape the talk to you to learn
more about dr. Bishop Singh's work and
the fascinating advances in machine
learning and neural program synthesis
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]